vítej zpět v Quantum Computing v praxi, jsem tvá hostitelka Olivia Lanes. Minule jsme prošli příkladem
kvantového přístupu k optimalizačnímu problému zvanému Max cut. Pomocí formulace QUBO jsme šli
poměrně do hloubky, ale byl to jen jeden příklad jednoho přístupu. Dnes budeme diskutovat o near-term aplikacích
obecněji a rozvineme naši intuici pro různé typy problémů, pro které očekáváme, že najdeme užitečná kvantová řešení,
a podíváme se na některé nedávné příklady důležité práce provedené v naší komunitě ve
utility scale. Dříve jsme stručně probrali, že ne všechny problémy potřebují další výpočetní výkon –
konkrétně Quantum Computing – k tomu, aby byly efektivně vyřešeny. Jsou to problémy, které již nejlépe
znáš: aritmetika, scrollování sociálních médií, možná hraní Tetrisu, Doomu nebo jiných videoher. Tyto obecně považujeme za
snadné problémy. Na druhé straně existují velmi těžké problémy, jako je nalezení prvočinitelů obrovských
čísel – to je základ RSA šifrování a k čemu byl Shorův algoritmus vlastně navržen. Dalším
příkladem je nalezení řešení v nesetříděné datové sadě. To lze teoreticky vyřešit kvantovým algoritmem
zvaným Groverův algoritmus. Většina odborníků se však shoduje, že tyto typy algoritmů budou vyžadovat
implementaci opravy chyb a technologicky tam ještě nejsme. Takže jak budeme pokračovat v této
lekci a ve svém kvantovém vzdělávacím putování, pamatuj, že hledáme toto sladké místo někde uprostřed.
Je to těžký problém k vyřešení, ale proto je to také tak zábavné. Jedna věc, o které jsme zatím moc
nemluvili, je teorie výpočetní složitosti. Jedním z důvodů je, že může být poněkud zastrašující a ano,
složitá. Teorie výpočetní složitosti je obor informatiky, který se snaží klasifikovat výpočetní problémy
podle toho, jak obtížné jsou. Existuje tuna různých tříd složitosti v klasickém computingu, ale nejzákladnější
jsou tyto: problémy P – to jsou problémy, které lze vyřešit v polynomiálním čase při škálování s
růstem problému, což znamená, že jsou snadno řešitelné. Dalším obtížnějším typem problémů jsou problémy NP, které
znamenají nedeterministický polynomiální. Jsou to problémy, jejichž odpovědi lze ověřit v polynomiálním čase, ale ne
nutně vyřešit. Dále je NP-complete a teď se dostáváme k opravdu náročným problémům bez
znám polynomiálního řešení. Zde žijí slavné problémy jako problém obchodního cestujícího a dokonce hra
Sudoku. Když Quantum Computing přišel – alespoň v teorii – lidé věnovali značné úsilí snaze
přijít na to, jakou třídu problémů tyto nové typy počítačů budou schopny efektivně řešit. Nová třída
problémů byla vynalezena nazvaná BQP – Bounded-error Quantum Polynomial problems. Jejich přesná definice je
trochu dlouhá, ale je to třída rozhodovacích problémů řešitelných kvantovým počítačem v polynomiálním čase s malou
šancí na chybu. Šance na chybu existuje, protože kvantové měření je inherentně náhodné, ale pravděpodobnost
chyby může být libovolně malá. Všechny tyto třídy žijí ve větší třídě nazývané PSPACE a tam
si myslíme, že BQP žije relativně ke všem ostatním typům problémů, ale je velmi těžké to definitivně prokázat
matematicky. Všimneš si, že BQP kvantové problémy se nemusí nutně překrývat s NP-complete problémy.
Možná jsi ale stále viděl/a některé kvantové přístupy, které se snaží řešit NP-complete problémy. Proč by
to bylo? Jedním běžným nedorozuměním je, že nemá smysl zkoumat řešení
problémů jako problém obchodního cestujícího a jiné NP-complete problémy pro kvantový počítač nebo jakýkoli problém, pro který
matematický důkaz kvantového zrychlení nebyl nalezen. To však nemusí být nutně pravda.
Nalezení matematického důkazu, že kvantový algoritmus je rychlejší než jeho klasický protějšek, je vzácné. Shor a
Grover jsou dva z mála příkladů, kde to bylo dosud provedeno. Ale to je v pořádku. Ve skutečnosti vědci
stále ještě nebyli schopni dokázat, že třídy P a NP jsou různé, i když veškerá intuice
nám říká, že musí být. Také srovnávání dvou algoritmů a toho, jak škálují, se často dívá na scénář nejhoršího případu
pro každý z nich. Je zcela možné, že v praxi scénář nejhoršího případu není to, co nacházíme v reálném životě. Takže se
netrápíme a místo toho představujeme myšlenku heuristických řešení. Pokud jsi
experimentalista, tato řešení již znáš a miluješ. Heuristika je jakýkoli přístup k řešení
problému, který je pragmatický, ale ne nutně optimální. A to je skvělé, protože řešení nemusí nutně být
optimální, aby byla velmi užitečná. Například si představ finanční aplikaci. Pro většinu finančních algoritmů, kde by se Quantum mohl
využít, jsme zatím nenašli exponenciální zrychlení. Ale to nutně nevadí – nepotřebujeme optimální řešení
ve financích alespoň proto, že řešení, které je o pouhé 1 % efektivnější, se může rovnat miliardám dolarů
zisku. Jak tedy víme, které případy použití a problémy by mohly být vhodné pro Quantum Computing právě teď? A tím myslím,
že existuje výrazný důvod věřit, že Quantum utility nebo dokonce Advantage lze nalézt buď nyní nebo
v poněkud blízké budoucnosti. Možná je snazší nejprve pojmenovat věci, které problém jistě mít nesmí.
Nemůže vyžadovat obrovský počet qubitů – zatím nemáme procesory s tisíci až miliony dostupných qubitů. To je jeden z hlavních důvodů,
proč jsou Shorův algoritmus a podobné tak daleko v budoucnosti. Circuits také nemohou být neuvěřitelně hluboké. Je mi opravdu těžké
přesně říct, jaká hloubka circuit nebude fungovat, protože záleží na tolika faktorech. Ale obecně, pokud tvůj
experiment vyžaduje hloubku, která ještě nebyla dosažena v literatuře, možná tě čekají těžké časy. A
nakonec jakýkoli typ algoritmu, o kterém víme, že bude vyžadovat opravu chyb, zatím nelze provést. Co bychom však měli hledat, jsou experimenty, které
využívají většinu dostupných qubitů na jakémkoli daném QPU. Zdůraznili jsme také
důležitost potlačování a zmírňování chyb a nakonec by mělo existovat zjevné rozšíření na budoucí
aplikace, které by byly důležité pro společnost a mohly by nakonec vést ke Quantum
Advantage. Teď si promluvme o několika příkladech případů použití, které spadají do tří hlavních kategorií, jež jsme
identifikovali jako nejpravděpodobnější k dosažení příznivých výsledků v krátkodobém až střednědobém
horizontu. První oblastí je simulace přírody. O tomto jsme již dříve mluvili –
existuje tolik příležitostí pro kvantové počítače zlepšit výzkum prováděný na molekulární a atomové úrovni.
WEBVTT
A důvodem je, že současné klasické metody jsou omezeny fundamentálně neefektivními matematickými
popisy atomových struktur. Ukládání a manipulace s kvantovým stavem vyžaduje exponenciální množství zdrojů
na klasickém počítači, ale lze to provést efektivně na kvantovém počítači, a proto je simulace materiálů
a chemické modelování jednou z nejslibnějších aplikačních oblastí. Konkrétněji by to mohlo vést k
vývoji v sekvestraci oxidu uhličitého, alternativních bateriích nebo vynálezu nových léků. Některé
algoritmy, které jsou v této oblasti zvláště relevantní, jsou variační kvantový eigensolver VQE, který se používá k
odhadování určitých vlastností materiálu, jako jsou rovnovážné nebo minimální energetické stavy. Dalším příkladem je
simulace dynamiky v čase – TDS. Tento algoritmus se používá k odhadování odpovídajících funkcí nebo spektrálních vlastností
materiálů. A chtěl/a bych také zmínit nováčka – Sample-Based Quantum Diagonalization – o které si myslíme, že o ní budeme
slyšet mnohem více v blízké budoucnosti. Další aplikační oblastí je optimalizace. Optimalizace je docela
všudypřítomná v computingu, jak si dokážeš představit, takže případy použití jsou poměrně četné a rozmanité.
Ale některé příklady, o kterých hodně slyšíme, jsou optimalizace portfolia ve financích, průmyslový design a také
distribuce a dodavatelský řetězec. Nejběžnější algoritmus, který pravděpodobně uslyšíš v souvislosti s optimalizací, je ten, který jsme
již do jisté hloubky probrali – quantum approximate optimization algorithm neboli
qaoa. A nakonec oblast, které se věnuje hodně nadšení v posledních několika letech – kvantové strojové učení. Myslím, že je
férové říct, že to vypadá, že QML se nestane tak brzy jako simulace – ve vší pravděpodobnosti – ale přesto existují
některé působivé algoritmy, na kterých lidé konzistentně pracují, odpovídající některým velmi důležitým případům
použití. Některé z těchto možných případů použití jsou zpracování přirozeného jazyka, analýza síťového provozu a dokonce detekce
podvodů ve finančních transakcích. Relevantní algoritmy v této oblasti jsou kvantový support vector
machine, kvantové neuronové sítě a kvantové generativní adversariální sítě. Abych objasnil/a – ty tři
skupiny, které jsme právě popsali, jsou široké aplikační oblasti. Stojí také za zmínku, že v komunitě je
výhodné i pro skupiny pracující společně, které se zaměřují na konkrétní téma. IBM inicioval/a iniciativu ne tak dávno
nazvanou Working Groups, aby pomohl/a spolupracovníkům setkat se a vytvořit produktivní synergii ve čtyřech konkrétních
oblastech: zdravotní péče a biovědy, materiály a HPC, fyzika vysokých energií a
optimalizace. Zde jsou naše aktuální skupiny a subjekty zapojené do těchto snah. Pokud chceš slyšet více o tom,
co Working Groups dělají, přiložili jsme čtyři jejich bílé knihy v popisu níže. Teď, jak jsem řekl/a,
nejlepší věc, kterou v tuto chvíli v kurzu udělat, je strávit čas prozkoumáváním toho, na jakých problémech lidé pracují na špičce
této technologie, a rozvíjet naši intuici pro to, jaké typy algoritmů budou fungovat a jak
je aplikovat. A než začneme, chci jasně říct, že hlavním cílem není porozumět každému
detailu experimentů. Tento typ analýzy může být velmi zastrašující i pro experty, pokud je článek mírně
mimo jejich oblast odbornosti. Cílem je jednoduše pomoci rozvíjet intuici pro typy problémů, pro které jsou kvantové
počítače dobré, a jak s nimi zacházet. A pokud tě zajímají jemnější detaily a toto ti dalo nějaké
vlastní nápady, rozhodně tě povzbuzuji, abys šel/šla a přečetl/a celé články. Konkrétní případy použití a
články, na které se budeme podrobně dívat, jsou tyto: nejprve prozkoumáme článek, který diskutuje
simulaci dynamiky hadronů – to spadá do kategorie fyziky vysokých energií. Dále se podíváme na
optimalizační problém, konkrétně Bias Field Counter-Adiabatic Quantum Optimization. A nakonec se podíváme na další
simulační problém, ale tentokrát se zaměřením na mRNA – klíčovou molekulu pro
vývoj léků a terapeutik. Ať jsi s těmito články obeznámen/a nebo ne, nevadí. Projdeme si je –
všechny tři jsou důležité články, které řeší problémy podstatné velikosti a ukazují, jak jsou kvantové
počítače začínají být používány jako další metoda vědeckého výzkumu. Jako první je simulace dynamiky hadronů.
Ponoříme se do článku Martinovy Savageovy skupiny na University of Washington nazvaného Quantum
Simulations of Hadron Dynamics in the Schwinger Model Using 112
Qubits. Pokud nejsi fyzik/fyzička vysokých energií, možná znáš pojem hadron například z
Large Hadron Collider neboli LHC – toho gigantického urychlovače částic 27 kilometrů v obvodu, který umožnil
konečně pozorovat Higgsův boson. Hadron je subatomární složená částice složená z dalších malých
částic nazývaných kvarky. Některé příklady by byly neutrony a protony. Pro trochu kontextu byl LHC postaven
k umožnění studia fundamentální fyziky a toho, co se děje s částicemi, když se sráží při velmi vysokých energiích
v tomto kruhovém potrubí. Tímto vědci doufají naučit se více o tom, jak vznikl raný vesmír,
a jak jsem již řekl/a, byl také použit k nalezení Higgsova bosonu, který je nepolapitelnou částicí zodpovědnou za hmotnost
fundamentálních částic. Principiálně by interakce těchto částic mohly být
simulovány od začátku do konce dostatečně výkonným kvantovým počítačem. Ještě tam nejsme, ale pokrok
se děje. Schwingerův model je jednoduchý model používaný k simulaci některé z těchto dynamik a stal se jedním z
nejpopulárnějších modelů podle výběru. Podrobnosti modelu nejsou teď super důležité, ale pro ty,
kdo jsou zvědaví: jde o model, který popisuje chování elektronů a pozitronů interagujících prostřednictvím fotonů v 1+1 D
dimenzích, což znamená, že existuje jedna prostorová dimenze a čas. Model má hodně podobností s kvantovou
chromodynamikou, která popisuje, jak kvarky a hadrony interagují. To je extrémně těžké simulovat, takže
Schwingerův model se často používá jako hračkový model k zkoumání některých jevů, které jsou společné
oběma. Způsob, jakým budeme postupovat s tímto příkladem a se zbytkem příkladů, které jsem vybral/a, je
kladení sérii otázek. První je: proč jsme měli důvod věřit, že simulace tohoto
na kvantovém počítači vůbec bude fungovat? V tomto případě mají elektrony a pozitrony ve Schwingerově modelu stínovací
efekt, způsobující exponenciální pokles korelací mezi vzdálenými fony se separací. To znamená, že tam
WEBVTT
nejsou tolik dlouhodobých interakcí od qubitu na jedné straně čipu k druhé na druhé straně čipu,
o níž víme, že je velmi náchylná k chybám. Takže to je opravdu dobré pro hardware, který máme dnes k dispozici. Dále je
toto téma vůbec zajímavé? Doufám, že jsem tě již přesvědčil/a, že ano – fyzika vysokých energií je velmi
zajímavá. Lidé byli ochotni utratit miliardy dolarů na stavbu LHC a tisíce vědců a
techniků po celém světě zasvětilo svůj život tomuto oboru. Tak moc je to důležité. Ale
Schwingerův model je zjednodušený a není navržen k pokrytí tří prostorových dimenzí. Přesto je to
důležitý model, protože stále poskytuje momentálně testovatelné řezy a užitečné zjednodušení plné
teorie. A nakonec: jak tato práce byla provedena nebo jaký přístup by použili, kdyby chtěli pokračovat v práci v
simulačních typech experimentů? VQE je jedním z nejběžnějších přístupů a první krok je téměř vždy stejný –
připravit základní stav. V tomto případě jde o vakuový stav a v tomto experimentu použili novou verzi VQE nazvanou SC-adapt VQE
k přípravě jak základního stavu, tak hadronového vlnového balíčku na vrcholu vakua. Dalším krokem je pak
nechat hadrony vyvíjet nebo propagovat v čase. Nakonec potřebujeme identifikovat
pozorovatelné, které chceme detekovat. Pokud ti tyto kroky zněly poněkud povědomě – mimo část s hadronovým vlnovým
balíčkem – je to proto, že tyto kroky jsou velmi podobné tomu, co jsme probrali v příkladu qaoa v předchozí epizodě.
Doufejme, že začínáš vidět vzorce. Komponenty potřebné pro VQE jsou velmi podobné jako u qaoa –
začínáme ve známém stavu (zde vakuový stav) a poté ho necháme vyvíjet v čase se sérií exponenciovaných
hamiltonianů rozdělených do zvládnutelných bloků, kde n je počet rozdělení. Jediný velký rozdíl je,
že vytváříme vlnový balíček hadronu soustředěný v našem circuit, než ho začneme nechávat vyvíjet. Jak se to
dělá? Vakuový stav je základní stav a to, jak ho namapovat, jsme již trochu probrali. Nyní příprava hadronového
vlnového balíčku je trochu jiná. Na tomto vakuu lze hadron excitovat vytvořením fermion-antifermionového páru na
sousedních místech. Přípravou superpozice takových hadronů na různých místech lze připravit libovolný vlnový
balíček. Autoři soustředili svůj vlnový balíček uprostřed circuit, aby mohli pozorovat vývoj
bez překročení hranice. Ale pamatuj, že při práci s šumivými QPU je jménem hry udržet
hloubku circuit zvládnutelnou. K tomu protokol SC-adapt VQE používá symetrie a
hierarchie v délkových škálách k určení low-depth Quantum circuits pro přípravu stavů. Myšlenka je, že tím
vznikne ansatz s menším počtem parametrů, což odpovídá mělší hloubce. Více podrobností lze samozřejmě
najít v článku, než zde máme čas pokrýt, takže si ho určitě přečti. Teď se podíváme na výsledky. Tento experiment byl spuštěn na
IBM Quantum Heron zařízení a implementoval několik různých typů potlačování a zmírňování chyb
včetně novější techniky nazývané operator decoherence renormalization, stejně jako dynamical decoupling, zero noise
extrapolation a Pauli twirling. Teď se pokusme interpretovat data. Pozorovatelnou, kterou skutečně budeme
měřit k pozorování propagace vlnového balíčku, je něco nazývané chirální kondenzát, což je trochu
abstraktní, ale v podstatě jde o superfázovou fázi hadronů. Vidíme vlnový balíček soustředěný zde na
místech, která byla určena pro tento experiment, kde barva odpovídá chirálnímu kondenzátu.
Levá strana ukazuje bezchybné výsledky ze simulátoru, zatímco pravá strana ukazuje výsledky z IBM kvantového
počítače Torino. Ideálně by to měly být zrcadlové obrazy kvůli symetrii, takže vidíš, že existují
určité nedokonalosti. Tato vertikální osa y odpovídá časovým blokům, které jsem
měřil/a dříve. Proč neuděláme horizontální řezy přes první a poslední časový krok dat, abychom viděli,
co se stane s vlnovým balíčkem. V čase tau=1 zde oranžově odpovídající
tomuto řezu vidíš, že chirální kondenzát je úzký a lokalizovaný. Odpovídá také velmi dobře
simulaci provedené pro srovnání. Při tau=14 je však mnohem více rozložený a méně
lokalizovaný. Možná srovnání se simulátorem není tak dokonalé, ale stále je zřejmě vidět velmi dobrou shodu mezi teorií a daty,
což je povzbudivé. Závěrem jde o velmi skvělý příklad typu simulační práce, o níž si na prvním místě nemusíš myslet
při aplikaci kvantových počítačů. Ve skutečnosti to ale jde a funguje to. Není to dokonalé, ale nemusíš být
expert na fyziku částic, abys viděl/a, že kvantový počítač přesně předpovídá vnější propagaci vlnového balíčku,
což je přesně to, co bychom očekávali najít. Doufejme, že budoucí práce v této oblasti bude pokračovat a fyzici vysokých energií
budou nadále nacházet způsoby, jak začlenit Quantum Computing do svých pracovních toků. Cílem je řešit teoretické problémy přesněji a
ty, které nelze vyřešit klasicky, a používat experimenty k přijetí nebo odmítnutí teorií v naději na objev nové
fyziky, budování lepších detektorů a vedoucí k lepšímu porozumění přírody na její nejfundamentálnější
úrovni. Náš další příklad se zaměřuje na optimalizaci a bude hloubkovým ponořením do článku nazvaného Biased Field
Digitized Counter-Adiabatic Quantum Optimization, který byl vypracován členy týmu Kipu Quantum a
Univeristou Baskické země ve Španělsku. Začneme jako předtím
s řadou definicí. První je counter-adiabatic, což je typ vývoje, který potlačuje non-adiabatické
efekty, jimiž systém prochází bez ohledu na to, jak rychle tyto procesy probíhají. Vzpomeň si na adiabatický teorém z
minulé epizody. Obvykle musíš nechat systém vyvíjet velmi pomalu, pokud chceš, aby zůstal v základním stavu.
To je velký problém, protože čím pomaleji musíme věci nechat vyvíjet, tím více času máme na výskyt chyb.
Counter-adiabatic driving, často zkráceně CD, se snaží tomu čelit přidáním členů,
které potlačují tyto nežádoucí excitace. Hlavní myšlenkou je urychlit celý experiment a
snížit hloubku Quantum circuit potlačením excitací, které by mohly vést k nežádoucím
přechodům. Teď si promluvme o tom, co je bias field. Jiné iterativní algoritmy jako VQE přijímají klasické parametry do
těchto stavů a používají klasické optimizery k prohledávání vícerozměrného prostoru parametrů pro sadu
parametrů, která dává minimální střední hodnotu pro pevný hamiltonian. V tomto případě místo toho mění hamiltonian každý
WEBVTT
krok, adiabaticky přecházejíc ze známého případu k případu zájmu. Ale protože nejsou předávány žádné klasické parametry
a není žádná variační vlnová funkce, jak aktualizuješ svůj stav z jednoho průchodu hamiltonianem na další? Přidají
bias field do hamiltonianu. Jakýkoli stav s nejnižší energií z předchozího běhu přidají jako člen do
hamiltonianu, aby stav ovlivnili ve prospěch toho. Proč je tedy tento experiment
zajímavý? Především jde o nový přístup, který by mohl být aplikován obecněji na jiné optimalizační problémy.
V tomto případě ho aplikovali na problém Isingova spin glass. Jak jsme diskutovali dříve, mnohé kombinatorické
optimalizační problémy lze přeformulovat jako řešení pro nízkoenergetické stavy Isingových hamiltonianů. Isingův
model je řada mikroskopických spinů rozložených na poli. Model lze použít k popisu spin glass, ve kterém
je magnetizace neuspořádaná – v podstatě malé magnetické momenty jsou v poli orientovány náhodně. A
proč jsme si mysleli, že to bude fungovat? Již jsme trochu probrali, jak bojujeme se dvěma typickými problémy nalezenými v
variačních algoritmech, když jsme pokryli definice článku. Ale pro shrnutí – algoritmus, který
navrhují, urychluje vývoj ke snížení hloubky circuit při potlačování non-adiabatických přechodů.
Navíc nespoléhá na žádnou klasickou optimalizační rutinu, která může být problémem vedoucím k Barren
plateaus a uvíznutí v lokálních minimech. A nakonec autoři také dbají na to, aby interakce v problémovém
hamiltonianu byly v souladu s konektivitou hardwaru v reálném QPU, což je vždy velmi důležité. A nakonec: jak to funguje?
Jak jsem řekl/a, zde se nepoužívají žádné klasické optimizery, jak to bývá v iterativních kvantových algoritmech.
Místo toho tím, že se řešení z každé iterace předává jako vstup pro další, Biased Field Digitized
Quantum Optimization algoritmus postupně zpřesňuje základní stav, přibližuje ho čím dál více k
konečnému vyvinutému stavu. A v kombinaci s counter-adiabatic protokoly to lze provést i s krátkými Quantum
circuits, které by měly hladce běžet na šumivém hardwaru. Takže když byl experiment proveden, autoři se rozhodli spustit
algoritmus na 127-qubitovém IBM quantum počítači Brisbane. Zde autoři ukázali
energetizaci optimalizačního algoritmu pro nearest-neighbor náhodně generovanou spin glass instanci
přes 100 qubitů. Porovnávají ideální výsledky simulace z DCQ a BF-DCQ
a také experimentální výsledek, a také ukazují výsledek z klasického solveru nazvaného Gurobi jako referenci.
Jen s 10 iteracemi BF-DCQ poskytuje drastické zlepšení oproti
DCQ. Ačkoli experimentální výsledek je trochu jiný než ideální výsledek kvůli šumu, výkon je stále
lepší než ideální DCQ. To ukazuje, že je stále dosahováno skvělého pokroku
v oblasti Quantum optimalizace a dobré výsledky jsou hlášeny na více než 100 qubitech poprvé.
A nakonec, ale rozhodně ne nejméně důležitý, je velmi zajímavý článek prozkoumávající predikci struktury mRNA od přátel z
Moderna Pharmaceuticals s názvem mRNA Secondary Structure Prediction Using Utility-Scale Quantum
Computers. Pokud, stejně jako já, jsi absolvoval/a kurz biologie před pár lety, osvěžme si,
co je mRNA. Messenger RNA je typ RNA zapojený do syntézy proteinů.
V podstatě čte instrukce dané DNA. Sekundární struktura mRNA je víceméně to, jak je řetězec složen, a
problém predikce sekundární struktury RNA je problémem nalezení nejstabilnějšího skládání sekvence
bází nukleotidů, které tvoří DNA a RNA – to by bylo C, G, U a A. Tento
obrázek ukazuje některé z běžných struktur skládání nalezených v mRNA, přičemž každá barva zvýrazňuje
jinou sekundární strukturu. Ale přesné charakteristiky toho, co dělá jednu z těchto struktur výhodnější nad
jinou, nejsou dobře pochopeny. Vše, co můžeme dělat, je zjistit, která z nich má nejnižší volnou energii ve srovnání s
nesloženým stavem, a tam přicházejí na řadu kvantové počítače. Proč jsou sekundární struktury mRNA
důležité? Přesná predikce jich je vlastně zásadní nejen pro pochopení DNA a našich genů, ale také
pro navrhování RNA-based terapeutik jako je vakcína proti covid-19. Existuje důvod věřit, že přístup v
tomto článku by fungoval, protože to byl odedávna formidabilní optimalizační problém pro klasické
počítače kvůli obrovskému počtu možných konfigurací. A pro některé konfigurace je to ve skutečnosti known to be
NP-complete problém. Na kvantovém počítači však lze predikci sekundární struktury formulovat jako
binární optimalizační problém – něco, co víme, jak zpracovat. Navíc v literatuře již existuje důkaz
přesné predikce RNA na malých kvantových zařízeních a kvantových simulátorech. Takže zjevná otázka je:
fungovalo by to na větším hardwaru? Experiment je proveden pomocí něčeho nazvaného Conditional Value
at Risk Variational Quantum Eigensolver, což je modifikace tradičního algoritmu VQE a
očekává se, že dosáhne lepší konvergence. Tento graf ukazuje distribuci pravděpodobností měření
vzorkovacích bitových řetězců s odpovídajícími energiemi pro 42
nukleotidovou 80-qubitovou instanci. Zde bitové řetězce symbolizují párování
nukleotidů. Ilustruje, že bitový řetězec s nejnižší energií má energetickou hodnotu −140, která odpovídá nejnižší
energetické síle nalezené srovnávacím klasickým solverem. To je skvělé a toto je optimálně složená
struktura tohoto nukleotidového řetězce na základě bitového řetězce s nejnižší energií, které hardware
nalezl. A tím jsme dosáhli závěru této epizody. Mým záměrem zde nebylo zahltit tě
podrobnostmi z různých výzkumných článků. Jak jsem řekl/a, jednoduše jsem ti chtěl/a poskytnout dostatek kontextu k pochopení toho,
jak vypadá špičková práce v oboru právě teď. Doufám, že toto rozeběhne v každém nějaké myšlenky
a tím, že uvidíš, jak ostatní přistupují k problémům, budeš schopen/schopna vytvářet spojení a mít
odvahu pokoušet se o nové kvantové experimenty, o které ses dříve neodvážil/a. A hej, možná některé z nich nevyjdou
a to je v pořádku – to je důvod, proč jde o výzkum. Pamatuj, že typy problémů, o které se
zajímáme, lze seskupit buď podle metodologie nebo podle předmětu, a my jsme vytyčili ty, které považujeme za
WEBVTT
nejslibnější v krátkodobém horizontu. Pamatuj, že Quantum Computing není dobrý pro vše a je to vlastně
svědectví o tom, jak dobří jsme se stali v klasickém computingu. Jen proto, že si myslíš, že bys mohl/a aplikovat Quantum Computing
na problém, neznamená, že to přinese zajímavé výsledky. Bohužel musíš zvážit škálování. Hloubka circuit je dvousečná
zbraň – potřebujeme ji být značně velkou, abychom dělali zajímavou práci, kterou klasické počítače nemohou,
ale právě teď kvůli hardwarovému šumu ji nemůžeme tlačit na obrovské velikosti, protože Fidelity se
sníží. Jde o nalezení toho sladkého místa s vědomím, že je to pohyblivý cíl. Takže si vezmi čas
mezi nyní a příštím dílem opravdu přemýšlet o některých problémech, na které jsi narazil/a, a o tom, jak bys k nim mohl/a přistoupit s tím, co jsme se
naučili do tohoto bodu. Buď kreativní a nelimituj se. A pokud máš nějaké nápady, i když si myslíš, že jsou trochu
bláznivé, dej mi vědět v komentářích níže. Díky za sledování a uvidíme se příště.